le Québec doit donner les moyens de ses
ambitions à son ministère de
l'Environnement s'il souhaite absolument
atteindre ses objectifs climatiques
c'est l'appel lancée par l'ex
journaliste Louis Gilles Francoeur dans
un ouvrage qui paraît aujourd'hui la
caution verte aux éditions éco-société
louisville-francard et notre invité
bonsoir
bonsoir je dis avec journaliste mais
dans le fond toujours journaliste
qui a été fait dans ce livre là vous
démontrer que depuis Robert Bourassa
depuis le début des années 90 le
ministère de l'Environnement et là je
vous cite est un accompagnateur un
aidant naturel des promoteurs et du
développement économique est-ce que vous
dites que fondamentalement le Québec n'a
jamais donné les moyens de ses ambitions
à son ministère d'environnement ben
c'est ce que je voulais vérifier en
profitant de la retraite je lui dis
est-ce que le ministère a les moyens de
ses ambitions
à partir de mon poste d'observation ou
de voir et
les chiffres ça ment pas est-ce qu'on a
découvert c'est que finalement
contrairement à 0 prétention promesse
des gouvernements qui disent que
l'environnement est un énorme priorité
mais le budget de ministère de
l'Environnement vous savez il s'est
promené il se promène depuis une
quinzaine d'années entre 1/4 et un tiers
de 1 %
du budget de l'État c'est très très peu
et on voit aussi que le ministère sans
compas par exemple au ministère de la
Santé ben voyez-vous il y a à l'époque
de l'an 2000 le budget annuel du
ministère correspondait à 5 jours et
demi du budget de la santé mais depuis
ça a continué de baisser je voulais pas
que Marois c'est 2.3 jours puis le
monsieur Couillard 1.8 et on est
remontant un petit peu avec la CAF à
deux points 3 alors voyez-vous ça veut
dire que le ministère
et sous outillé avec autant de missions
on a augmenté ses responsabilités avec
le temps et il se retrouve aujourd'hui
avec le même personnel qu'il y a 30 ans
en 1990 et vous allez jusqu'à dire qu'il
y a abdication de l'État pour contrôler
les agissements des agents économiques
il y a beaucoup de chiffres c'est un peu
aride mais les amateurs de chiffres
seront servis parce que vous avez voulu
éplucher avec votre collègue de l'Irak
éplucher les budgets éplucher les
politiques pour démontrer très
clairement que depuis les années 70 ce
ministère n'a jamais rempli totalement
sa fonction mais le milieu d'affaires
dit pas ça c'est le contraire on a
l'impression moi j'ai déjà entendu un
maire me dire c'est pas le ministère de
l'Environnement c'est le ministère de
l'empêchement et puis effectivement
d'inspecteurs environnementaux
changement c'était de dire la clientèle
du ministère pas population qui les
espèces s'envoient les écosystèmes c'est
maintenant les demandeurs de permis mais
les demandeurs de permis c'est les gros
projets qui quelque part les sons de
Martin l'environnement et depuis ce
temps-là le ministère s'est perçu comme
de plus en plus un accompagnateur alors
là où il faudra règlement dans le
domaine minier on a mis une directive et
on fixe des objectifs environnementaux à
atteindre qui ne sont pas obligatoire on
a institué par exemple en inspection du
côté des entreprises c'est l'auto
contrôle par le personnel ou les
consultants des entreprises le côté
municipal en sommet des rapports
contrairement au nord on les poursuit si
ce n'est pas les rapports attends ouais
mais les infractions de pollution ça
existe à peu près pas vous parler de la
dépollution de l'eau justement qui n'est
pas bien suivi les rivières notamment la
Fondation rivière qui a fait beaucoup de
travail vous parlez d'utilisation des
fosse septiques au Québec également
de l'agriculture aussi tout ça contribue
à ces fameux cyanobactéries exactement
au vieillissement si on veut des cours
d'eau
le ministère a eu un gros départ dans
les années 80 avec le programme
d'assainissement des eaux mais ce
programme s'est arrêté en 93 et là il y
a un gros trou ça repart un peu et là
c'est paradoxal au Québec grâce à un
règlement fédéral qui date de 2012 et
qui commence à s'appliquer maintenant
donc avec des gens un énorme retard et
les derniers ouvrages secondaires les
derniers traitements secondaires seront
installés au Québec en 2040 pour
compléter mais on n'est pas rendu au
traitement tertiaire et là pendant tout
ce temps-là ce sont ajoutés des
nanoparticules se sont ajoutés des
astringent se sont ajustées les produits
pharmaceutiques tout ça de plus en plus
omniprésent dans les eaux usées des
villes
en fonction de ça les populations
augmentées mais les usines sont toujours
calibrées pour les populations des
années 80-90 alors le retard que le
Québec a pris et quand même extrêmement
important calcul que c'est 17 milliards
pour rattraper ça quand même et en
terminant parce qu'on a vraiment pas
beaucoup de temps vous proposer la
création d'un faux climat plutôt que le
fond vert qu'on connaît ou
d'électrification
pour le donner au ministère des
Ressources naturelles et on a dit lui il
va être responsable de la politique
énergétique l'environnement
là-dessus alors on se retrouve au fond
avec deux fonds de capitaine pour
diriger la lutte au changement
climatique alors on a eu 5 plan de lutte
Auchan à la crise climatique tous ont
échoués et celui qui est en cours c'est
clair tout le monde le dit la cible est
pratiquement déjà impossible à atteindre
mais avec deux capitaines
et le on pourra pas réagir avant 202526
si on voit qu'on a du retard alors ça
veut dire que finalement le ministère a
pas les moyens le vérificateur général
répète pour ces 5 plans les mêmes
critiques depuis 15 ans la suite est
là-dedans la caution verte merci
beaucoup Louis Gilles francker d'avoir
été avec nous mais c'est un plaisir
rendez-vous sur la chaîne ici RDI
[Musique]